what's up guys bang bang there's a
bitcoiner now running for prime minister
of canada as many of you know there's
tons of stuff all over the news in
canada where there's authoritarian
actions being taken people's freedoms
being taken away from them and lots of
nonsense in general well now pierre one
of the politicians that you've probably
seen the viral videos of him standing up
in parliament going ahead and explaining
what sound money is how inflation is
taxation and also just generally
advocating for citizens to come back
take back their rights and have freedom
a city a country and a state and a
province where the people do not fear
their government but the government
fears their people that's right there is
a bitcoiner now running for prime
minister of canada here's a little bit
of the video from his announcement of
him running for prime minister the
trudeau government has attacked small
businesses
truckers and other hardworking canadians
they target law-abiding hunters and
farmers while letting gangsters and gun
smugglers run free see here's the
problem trudeau thinks he's your boss
he's got it backwards
you are the boss that's why i'm running
for prime minister to put you back in
charge of your life
together
we will make canadians the freest people
on earth with freedom to build a
business without red tape or heavy tax
freedom to keep the fruits of your labor
and share them with loved ones and
neighbors
freedom from the invisible thief of
inflation freedom to raise your kids
with your values freedom to make your
own health and vaccine choices freedom
to speak without fear and freedom to
worship god
in your own way see in a free country
smaller government
makes room for bigger citizens people
have room to take responsibility for
themselves and each other
neighbors care for neighbors a job is
the best anti-poverty program
and family and community are the best
safety net
now the people with power the media
interest groups corporate giants
government authorities
will fight tooth and nail to keep on top
so it won't be easy
but easy street leads to a dead end and
hard roads lead to the best destinations
our destination is a canada where the
government is servant
not master
as henley might say
you are the master of your fate
you
are the captain of your soul now i gotta
say i didn't think that we'd have a
bitcoin running for prime minister of
canada this quickly but i sure love to
see it good luck to pierre and i hope
all the people of canada are paying
attention
somebody who understands sound money
somebody who understands inflation and
taxation somebody who generally is a fan
of giving freedom back to their citizens
well he's running for prime minister
let's see what happens